wow oh
my oh God now get those pants off
can you play a helicopter
is the back of your head look like a
huge penis
the answer is yes blade blade Hannibal
King waiting yeah National Lampoon's Van
Wilder oh yeah Green Lantern sorry
I respect that about you you're willing
to own all the bad movies you've been in
oh thank you
hello you know what I respect about you
you knew when to give up making movies
entirely
Ryan my beautiful Blake sexiest man in
the world all those things and yeah she
is the sexiest man yeah
you know do you know if it's boy or girl
we don't we never find out we always
wait till they they uh they come down
the Chute but you know I I actually
um
okay I think you should go now you're
absolutely right you're absolutely right
Jimmy I should go
I should go ahead and read the rest of
your monologue oh really you think you
could do this both Stan and read jokes
you know in our own way we late night
hosts are basically superheroes because
you're all mostly white men
[Applause]
um I don't like Ryan Reynolds at all
absolutely and [ __ ] yeah yeah did you go
to the Met Gala did I uh no I didn't in
fact I went to on a press tour so I
didn't have to go to the Met gal
who's your least favorite person you've
acted with Hugh Jackman
sorry do you did I say something
sometimes you can't hold it you're fine
this is you in there a show called 15.
there I am 13 years old oh it's a little
cherub if you only knew what I was up to
off camera
you get to wear the suit yeah which is a
nice you know kind of like I'm wearing a
suit yeah yeah well it's like a big red
body condom yeah sure whatever you want
I got one of those like scratches that
you just yeah no nothing there's nothing
that counts there's no space in that
thing at all when I put it on I can
actually taste my own genitals it's
disgusting
it has a pretty far out premise was it a
tough sell or were you attracted to it
immediately
God you look like a young Bill Pullman
now this is on tape and now it's guys
I've heard it like I hear it every day
of my life Mr President yes wow it's
that's incredible yeah all right what
the [ __ ] was the question Unstoppable
Hugh Jackman he's you know I've met him
once in the elevator here see there's
these monstrous that guy he's a he's a
beast made of indestructible things a
lot of people don't know this
um but I've heard that his nipples are
actual diamonds
foreign
oh my God poppies are my favorite thing
in the whole wide world and they're
Rob's favorite food yeah I thought you
said you hated children you know puppies
it was definitely children not puppies
though what have they ever done to my
sleep pattern say what you will about
Russian prisons the soap
it's incredible
spell it I'm not gonna smell it what
April Fool's Frank got me kicked out of
school oh that's a good one hey put a
rotten fish in my teacher's desk B stole
my teacher's car or C Street during a
high school football game I'm gonna say
for fun you stole your teacher's car
that is correct will I along with
several other friends including uh Jimmy
barbutis stole our teacher's car by
lifting it we actually lifted it and and
walked away yeah the color of confidence
we
that's the color confidence yeah yeah
and lavender underwear
you know what I respect about you
you fight against offensive stereotypes
like Canadians being likable
well you know
something I really really respect about
you is that you know the phrase dance
like no one is watching well you do
everything like no one is watching
[Applause]
I mean wow that was Joe Geary from
stranger things right behind me who's in
my movie the guy that we were there for
you should see you should look at this
back you can see him saving his beverage
he's not worried about watch watch watch
that's yeah he just went out of the way
you know you're not gonna believe this
but Donald Trump is in the news
the administration is still dealing with
a Fallout from Trump announcing that the
U.S will be pulling out of the Iran deal
it's Trump's biggest pulling out blunder
since Eric
right Ryan treated when he heard the
news of the consolation
Zane is another great Norton Show with
me anymore I'll still go but obviously I
got my lips done for nothing
really I'm lucky that I get to work in
this industry and particularly
incredibly fortunate I get to working at
this long but I really want to work with
people I either or that are either
immensely talented or people that I love
and that are I'm genuinely like best
friends with and unfortunately Hugh does
not qualify as either of those but but I
am I will shove a red card so far up
your ass that they will hold a funeral
for my hand
I will shove a red card so far up your
ass people will think it's your tongue I
will shove a red card so far up your ass
will need a team of doctors to find my
hand I will shove a red card so far up
your ass you will be legally
reclassified as a puppet
buckle up right you feel any pressure to
like do you care after you make so much
money do you even care if it flops or
not how do you I work for 20th Century
Fox what do you think I'm paid in spit
and inside
and I was like yeah they're all amazing
they're all like super huge Stars it's
gonna be it's gonna be awesome Brad
Pitt's gonna do it and they were like
wait hold on back up Brad Pitt's gonna
do this I was like yeah yeah he's
playing one of the characters they're
like which character I was like he's
gonna play the way banisher and they're
like what's what's vanisher's power and
I was like well he doesn't speak and
he's invisible
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
is it true that puberty didn't hit you
until like you're quite a week ago yeah
yeah I knew I I was 20 and I I knew
girls that had a a far more menacing
mustache than me I I don't know what
happened some sort of genetic uh anomaly
I just yeah I looked I just I looked
like a like an Asian girl until I was
about 21. what about him the glasses guy
glasses
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you have to stop saying that
you're going to move to Canada whenever
you're mad at something in the U.S as a
Canadian I'm sorry but no you can't I
know we're friendly but Canada is not
your safe house I mean we barely let
Canadians into Canada anymore so please
pick somewhere else I hear I hear
Finland is really lovely this time of
year